it's a it's a great honor for us to be
here not many people ever think of a
dialysis company so for divita and on
behalf of our 29,000 teammates thank you
for giving us a chance to Yap a little
bit about what we think about leadership
I will have to say one thing though to
the Dean that would then divita if you
call the musketry clothing a costume as
the uniform you're fired
the so yeah but we one mistake we allow
for Dean's anyway the ownership you
talked about the beginning in 1999
ownership very important concept in in
in leadership and it's if I can just
jump into that for one moment since the
Dean reminds me of the history back in
the beginning we had a different name we
started off to do something very
different I'll refer back to that a
timer till we start out with the
explicit intents of creating a special
community to say we're a community first
and a company second and so just as a
village which is what we call herself
the divita village just as in a village
it doesn't do you any good unless you
have a sustainable economy doesn't Yuna
get all your good intentions for what
you want to do for a community will fall
apart
similarly we wanted our company to be
successful but it was a community first
and as we began to as we embarked upon
this task of communicating with at that
point about 12,000 teammates they after
a while decided that they wanted to
change the name of the company more and
more people teammates we call them would
come up to to me and other executives
and say you know what this place is so
different we want to get rid of the old
name other than the fact it's an ugly
name totally don't care they'd be like
starting a Ferrari company and calling
it the red car company the we want a new
name and so we had the people select
thousands of people voted and picked the
name of the new company divita which
means he or she gives us a life and then
and then hundreds of people voted and
picked into elite logo and we went
through a six seven eight month process
involving about a thousand people to
pick our core values actually sitting
down in a room forcing people to sit
down in a room and the midst of a turn
around we're on the verge of bankruptcy
and put people in groups and say okay
let's start with this list of values 100
all motherhood and apple pie values
start with that list and pick out which
ones if you presume for a moment that
all know not all big companies have to
be the same if you presume for a moment
that companies can
be as different as people what values
would make the most difference for a
dialysis company for this dialysis
company in this decade in this country
which ones that make the most difference
and then it culminated in a vote in a
room with 800 people and that's where
the core values came from so the name
the logo the core values all came from
the the people of De Vita now what I was
asked to talk about today is a little
bit of a personal life journey and a
little bit about leadership and with
respect to the personal life journey I'm
reminded what someone once said which is
that usually when someone starts to talk
to you about their life story it's a lot
more about their story than about their
life and so I'll try to I'll try to
avoid that and and speak the facts about
different parts of my own journey to the
spot where I sit here today and then
with respect to leadership I'll try not
to be I'll try not to be boring and I'll
use a series of quotes as we step
through it just because in general these
other people are more articulate than I
and I think it's a better way to have a
shot at retaining in a divita with
30,000 people spread across about 1,800
locations it's very important that we
talk in ways that people can take away
and retain that that concepts get
wrapped up in in a saying and a slogan
and something that they can take away
and remember particularly since the
majority of our teammates don't have
college education I wanted to explain
the HBS part of this there could have
been got a lot of different reasons if I
went to Harvard instead of GSB one could
be that of course that's a school where
they force you through a rigorous
educational process for the wear
we're the revered and hallowed case
study method where you really grow this
sort of inherent innate powerful
leadership skills is used across the
board that could have been the reason it
wasn't however the reason I went to HBS
is the GSP was like gee just be rejected
me and so so I I just I just want to say
that about five years ago we had we had
one GSB person at this point we have 16
and I think we got the ratio about right
16 GSB people working for one HBS person
I think I think so so I I'm gonna go up
to the admissions office after this and
just let them know that I just want to
say thanks so so leadership management
is different than leadership a lot of
wildly successful companies financially
are not well led some are not even well
managed in general although it's it's
it's important to not overstate these
things management is more about the what
leadership is more about why management
is more focused on the task leadership
is more robust around the spirit with
which a taxes a task is executed and and
it's important to think about this
distinction and now go ahead and go to
the next slide Bret the because
management is a business skill so if you
want to get better at management you
accumulate tools in your business
toolbox you become a better business
person so management is a business skill
leadership we think is dominantly a
human skill and if that is true if that
premise is true then in order to become
a better leader you have to become a
better human and we think that is a
simple but powerful truth that that one
has to think about the case we believe
it's true you have to internalize that
and approach becoming a better human
with the same sort of creativity rigor
and relentlessness that one uses to
acquire business skills and I think in
many ways that's equally equally
difficult I should go to the next one
the there's different forms of a
different situation there's different
situations where leadership is required
in some cases it's quite easy for
example if you're a captain in the
Marines and there's a war to be won
there's not a lot of debate about what
the mission is
when I came to what was the old company
there was a turnaround there's not much
debate about the business aspect of the
mission so there's times when the world
delivers you a relatively clear mission
there's also times when the world
delivers you a relatively motivated team
so when you hire six people from
Stanford Business School to come and
work for you and a small investment
management firm motivation is
motivations are not really an issue
there there's other subtleties but there
are there are times in which the world
delivers to you a relatively clear
mission or a relatively motivated team
of folks or group of folks to work on it
there are other areas of life where the
leader creates the mission and that can
be a purely business external objective
but separately it can be more about the
type of environment which people are
going to work while they're pursuing
that objective which could be happier
more fun more innovative whatever and
the third level of leadership is when
you actually work to create a world
that's more fulfilling for a lot of
other human beings and that's easier if
it's a small number and harder if it's a
big number and so whenever you talk
about leadership it's pretty important
to segregate out when you're just
talking about having the most market
share or the most profit growth
something like that that's one form of
leadership it is a radically different
form of leadership to want to create a
highly differentiated environment for
the human beings in sort of normal ways
and it's a whole nother level to talk
about trying to create fulfilment
particularly if a part what you're
focused on is human beings that are not
like the folks here in this room but a
lot of you are going to be reaching
leadership management positions which
could be leadership positions where you
got a lot of folks not like you working
for you and a lot of folks not like you
that who's the likes are going to
influence and so this is where you have
to start developing a very personal
definition of what leadership means to
you and that's why we use this phrase a
lot at divita begin with the end in mind
as Stephen Covey made it well-known but
it came from a as I understand it of a
Buddhist monk before that begin with the
end in mind is a very powerful concept
that two to two times in life one is
right
or whenever you decided you wanted to
become a distinctively strong leader I
still remember the time I vividly
remember the time in fifth grade when
the teacher said who wants to run for
Student Council and and and I decided I
wanted to do that with all the
nervousness of putting up posters and
that terrible day when you walked up to
the front of the class to give your
halting speech and I and I remember a
part of what I literally thought is gee
I'd like you know as I sort of look out
it read books and stuff like that I'd
like to be a person someday who gets to
lead something and as horrified as I am
I better I guess you got to start doing
it and and as ignorant as I was in so
many ways it's one of the few things in
life I got like that Lee got right
leading is like everything else if you
want to get good at it
you have to do it you have to do it and
doing just normal things in normal ways
following all conventional paths and
taking conventional mainstream's within
whatever companies you where there are
firms you whether schools you're in is
is not the way to practice leadership
it's the way to learn and practice a lot
of other things and so if you take that
upon yourself if the end you have in
mind as of this moment or a year ago or
two years ago or three months from now
to become a strong leader then you
better start thinking about what it
takes and part of it takes doing it and
that doesn't mean you sort of make up a
leadership task and part of it is
studying people who do it learning about
it because it is just like everything
else some of you are more naturally
gifted in this area with either certain
functional skills or charismatic skills
or certain value skills or value based
behaviors but but it is a it is a
function it is a product of cumulative
learning and practice just like
everything else so that's so one
juncture would just begin with the end
in mind concept as relevant is like is
today if X years from now you'd like to
be a skilled a skilled leader a strong
leader a leader who does add value to
the lives of a lot of other human beings
who are not like the fortunate few in
this room a second time we begin with
the end in mind
is really important is when you're
starting whatever you do next when you
walk in that first time in that
environment or to your new team or to
your organization or the first time you
put in charge of something significant
and you need to look out to folks and
say this is the end I have in mind and
is it going to be an arrow and is it
going to be I'd like us to increase
sales by 13 percent a year and increase
margins slightly each year and I'd like
to have one new product which for years
that's one end in mind and then that's
the end that people will relate to you
around as a leader it can't be no I'd
like to do all those things and I'd like
to create a very strong and distinctive
culture within our group I'd like us to
be more team-oriented above whatever
that is or it could be something much
bolder either in humanistic terms or an
innovative terms of whatever else but
you only get one opportunity when you're
launching a new quest to articulate with
everyone paying very significant
attention to what your end is so when we
started at De Vita seven years ago we
went out and remember this is a
turnaround we're technically bankrupt if
one bank had asked for $1 we would have
had to fold up our fold up our tents and
so we'd spend their our very first
executive retreat we spent the first two
thirds of the day talking about how the
heck we make payroll how we improve our
cash collection how we get rid of the
shareholder lawsuit how we fill the half
of the executives positions where people
have been terminated or quit because
they were so sure we were going bankrupt
how we deal with the SEC investigation
at said it's that said then we use the
last third to start talking about the
mission and the values and a third of
the third of the people in the room had
a positive reaction to that the
executives saying well this is different
it must be pretty important because
we're talking about it at a time when
the ship's almost sinking and we've just
been bailing all morning and now we're
starting to talk about some island that
we can't even see a third were stirred
in the middle saying okay this is
interesting I will wait and see in a
third we're very negative feeling that
this was either foolish naive
manipulative do you think you're going
to keep us with with some namby-pamby
concept of a mission and values and
creating a special community and it's
hard it's hard to get up in front of a
group in that setting when you know that
a very substantial percentage the merge
by far the majority are not going to buy
into what you're saying they're going to
be at least modestly uncomfortable and a
very significant minority or maybe half
actually think you're full of it
and that's and that's the reality that
often happens if
if you want to say is it leader you
aspire to building something that's
highly differentiated that's quite
special and it doesn't exist yesterday
it's very easy to come into a place that
already has a healthy culture and say
I'm going to sustain it I'm gonna
enhance it a bit on the margins very
different but that's what that's what
leadership is about and you only get
that one shot because that's when people
start to sense and that act and all the
acts of follow that in fact you do
fervently sincerely vehemently have that
end in mind and if you don't have it in
mind it's never gonna happen if you
don't have it in mind you're not willing
to talk about it then the day to day
crush of operating reality will squeeze
it out because you're going to have bad
bosses you're going to have tough budget
so you're gonna have competitors who do
difficult things and what tends to get
squeezed out in all those in situations
is the dream so it becomes more of a job
hopefully a highly successful job a very
remunerative job but it then it verts to
being a pretty normal normal job for you
and the people that work for you that
said that that's the natural tendency to
tend back towards the mean of human
behaviors and only you the leader can
make clear that that's not acceptable
that that's not the end and by making it
clear making it public then you start to
squeeze out time so one thing we did
back there in the beginning is is the
turnaround is every six to eight weeks
we get on the phone with the top 700 800
people and in addition to giving a
business update like yes we met payroll
again and other things like that we
would ask an answer the following
question is what is the incremental
evidence since the last phone call they
call these voice of the village calls
what's the incremental evidence that
were serious about the mission and
values we didn't have to discuss each
component of the mission we had to
discuss each of the core values in the
first six seven months the core values
didn't exist yet just the mission but we
had to discuss a couple and this is very
powerful because when you say something
out loud people in general if they say
something up out loud they want to live
up to it even if it's highly qualitative
having to do with their own behaviors
and own aspirations etc so we set it way
out loud and so the way that worked in
the real world is that every six weeks
or so if you say the call is every eight
weeks two weeks before you'd be sitting
there at ten o'clock you would have just
finished working on some budget trying
to retain some customer negotiating some
pay or contract whatever in our world
and you'd say
scuse my language but you'd say oh
that calls coming up in two weeks and we
have to answer that question again
what's the incremental evidence that
we're serious about creating a
difference in place with respect to -
with respect to our mission and then
subsequently our values but you would do
it with you what it is is it often the
idea that didn't flow naturally while
you're already working 16 hours a day
came out then well gee if we were really
serious about that we would do this we
would create a scholarship program for
the kids and grandkids of our teammates
if we were real serious about this we
would do village service days where we
serve the communities where we where we
live if we were serious about this we
would launch an environmental program if
we were serious about this we would have
medical missions that go overseas if we
were serious about this we'd have a
safety net the kick take care of our
teammates who make twenty five thirty
thousand dollars a year then when cancer
strikes the spouse or when a fire burns
down or whatever there is no safety net
for those people and unless we're there
to provide it their life as they knew it
is over and so that's what happens with
every success of forced public event of
accountability as we came up with
additional programs real-world programs
that did did substantiate the premise
that we wanted to be different and the
message is had we not had that public
reckoning had we not had the public bar
that we set out had we not explicitly
said the end in mind despite the
embarrassment that came with it the
discomfort and some people feeling
manipulated or very skeptical or even
cynical had we not done that I can tell
you right now we would only done half of
what we have done over the last six or
seven years which is to create a place
with twenty nine thirty thousand people
a whole bunch of which a very high
percentage of which think they work for
a different kind of place where we
bought a similar company a couple years
ago and their turnover using the same
way just working in the same markets in
the exact same business often just
blocks apart their turnover was 38%
higher even though we paid the same I
was all work environment different
clinical outcomes better than other
places not driven because we're more
clinically insightful but because people
have a different feeling around the
place that they work can you go ahead
and flip to the next one please
the
in order to get yourself to navigate the
path of of leadership it's so important
to remember that just as beauties in the
eyes of the beholder leadership is in
the eyes of the lead because we each
have our so I have my self-image of what
I'm like as the leader you have your
self-image what you like as leader in
general we think we're pretty good
pretty good men and women it doesn't
matter at all what good leaders do is
make sure that they know how other
people experience them and attack that
with very significant rigor so for
example in our situation everybody
including me
gets a review every year done by an
outside person where you're scored with
respect to your behaviors as they relate
to the mission and values and for me for
example in my request my scores go to
the Board of Directors so if people are
thinking that whoa the words on that
banner the words in that plaque are nice
but not real they get to tell the board
of directors said they get to tell they
give me the gift of that of that
feedback and this is a relatively
extreme case but the important point is
there's a very good chance that half of
what you think about how other people
experience you as a leader is probably
wrong it misses the nuances it misses
the test of if they were asked whether
or not Mary Jones or Tom Smith really
intensely believes about certain core
values or in creating a certain type of
work environment it misses the fact that
a lot of cases they'll say no I'm not
saying Tommy or Mary are bad people but
they they don't hold those things that's
that close to their heart the business
the business imperatives the business
objectives Trump every time in such a
significant way that while they're they
don't they don't violate those rules I
would never I would never tell you that
there are leader who's actively
promoting those rules those values those
behaviors so so leadership is in the in
the eyes of the lead how does all this
relate to some near-term decisions for
you folks well picking a job picking the
job you're going to choose when you
leave here again this is all in the
conflicts that if if you are
contemplating wanting to become a
differentially talented effective strong
leader particularly for people not like
those in this room well then in choosing
a place to go work it is not logical to
pick a place that doesn't talk a lot and
invest
a lot and care a lot about leadership
they just well why would you go to a
play if you wanna really want to learn
something don't go to a place where most
of the people are not good at it that's
not that's not wise you might do that
later in life to run and transform it
but right now if you want to become a
great marketer don't go to a lousy
marketing place yeah you'll get more
risk marketing responsibilities perhaps
but that's not the what you need to
become great
what do you things you do need to become
greatest learn from people who are
really good at it and study them with
great intensity so as you pick a place
think about this and secondarily think
about the broader DNA of the place you
choose all organizations have DNA DNA
typically doesn't change much I'm always
struck now that I'm getting so darn old
when I talk about the brand image of
different firms on the campuses here and
at Harvard and northwestern and talk
about the word adjectives you would use
to describe different different
companies different firms and what's so
amazingly striking is that they're
virtually the same as if you had sat
down with eight students 25 years ago
virtually the same and despite all the
trials and tribulations that different
firms have had and and things that have
gone in their industries the adjectives
end up being the same DNA runs pretty
deep in most organizations unless
someone takes very active steps to
change it so respect the DNA of the
entity and don't be misled by the DNA of
some particular little department or
team you're joining because unless it's
your aspiration to stay there it's very
difficult to contemplate DNA shifting
and it is very relevant again
particularly the context of learning
about leadership and whether that's a
culture that treasures nurtures
celebrates rewards and invests in
leadership in addition to management for
me after Business School that translated
to decision to join Bain which was for
two reasons one I wanted someplace that
one of the consulting firm that was more
implementation oriented because I knew I
wanted to be an executive someday and
second because because versus the other
places that I was looking at they seem
more team oriented which to me had a lot
to do with what I wanted to do when I
grew up I wanted to be a team leader
that was it
that was my end in mind and so that was
a very heavy criteria separate from
anything else and picking where I went
to work so I just encouraged you
to contemplate the same stuff now I'm
going to switch gears radically and
switch to marriage the because in fact
it has since I spent time every year
with first years and second years
contemplating jobs and and often the
conversation turns to what is sort of
the rest of life like marriage the
obvious thing to say marriage is
relatively important effect on the on
the rest of your life by what's striking
for my wife and I who was also in HBS
grad and then became one of the first
female venture capitals in America is
how many of our friends no longer have
marriages there either about a third of
them a little over a third are divorced
as we look across the class roles and
there's about another 15 20 % for their
the love and the marriage is dead and so
that's pretty striking because these
people they're they're from schools like
this a bunch of them are from this
school and and what we see is their
couples where one of two things happen
to the ones that are most likely to have
a dead marriage or a or an ended
marriage one is when there's it was a
real differential capacity for continued
personal growth and the way this is
relates to leadership in part is that to
become a strong leader over time takes
that sort of commitment to sustained
personal growth that sort of
introspective nough self-awareness
courage to confront your weaknesses
courage to talk about them openly
courage to talk openly in public about
how their people experience you in a way
that you don't think it's fair you don't
think is accurate but it's just how they
experience you well similarly in in
marriages and a lot of the divorces and
stuff we've seen her from where there's
a different trajectory of personal
growth and the other is when one of this
one of the spouses gets way too focused
on on work and there's a tremendous
disconnect on that on that balance issue
and and how one's life goes has dramatic
impact on what kind of leader you can be
there's a there's a great Buddhist quote
one does not pour from an empty cup and
and the great marriage adds to your cup
and a low quality marriage takes away
from your cup and so it's an it's an
obviously important part of life and
some of the principles that make
important and take it up or down at the
same kind of things ironically and maybe
not intuitively obviously to what it
means to what it means to be a leader of
other human beings
yep and talking about leadership there's
always that question what makes what
makes a good leader it's a relevant
question it's worth discussion there's
lots of lists out there lots of
different books lots of different
articles it all worth many worthwhile in
in my mind there's a lot of overlap in
those in those lists as well and some of
us are slightly more appropriate for
someone if you're a CEO or president
than they are or something else but it's
valuable from from my experience at this
point I say gee those lists there those
are important but they tend to be
behaviors or skills or practices or
disciplines and and what I've come to
appreciate more over time is how much
it's not so much of those that matter
but what are the attributes the values
the aspects of the person's being that
allowed them to develop those skills
consistently practice those behaviors
possess that discipline etc so that
there's there's a root cause underneath
a lot of those lists which doesn't get
as much attention and has a lot more to
do with the with the human being and on
my list in that category and I think I
think we have this on a slide Brett if
you can go ahead and put it up well this
is I'll do a quick segue here this is a
different subject this is more of those
the more typical list of what you would
find in an article the point to make
here is in our organization we went
through a significant process with
hundreds of people to define what it
meant to be a divita leader and again
the exact list doesn't matter but what
matters a lot is having a very serious
conversation about it and forcing every
individual to reflect on what they think
is most important to hear what other
people think most important and to
instill this in their mind and then what
we do is try to remind people of what
they said a good leader was because and
that we were talking earlier today was
with with with Professor O'Reilly and
and the issue of reminding organizations
and leaders about core values and the
mission and what it means to be a leader
is a very big deal and the metaphor I
use it's like people thought why do
people go to church
and simply go to church every Sunday he
said why do you go to church every
Sunday because you hear you vote you've
had that Psalm read to you before you've
probably heard a similar someone for
though you go to church to be reminded
well similarly if you're trying to
create in the real world the real hectic
world a real world with budgets and
turnover and family conflicts etc the
real world of managing teams building
teams trying to create a differentiated
environment you've got to figure out a
way to remind people of what they dreamt
of remind people what they aspired to
and one of the ways to do it is by
making sure there's a reasonable
consensus on the right words one set of
right words and then making sure people
are reminded of it and that can be
through banners we do it through songs
we do it through slogans we do it
through an annual exercise where every
every single person is to sit for half
an hour and at a meeting where we're all
in the same room and reflect it and fill
out their own mission and values report
card and then if they want to talk about
it with others that are around their
table it's a part of every professional
development review that the first thing
you get is is your most important
message about your performance in your
professional development over the past
year the second section is comments than
you in the context of every one of our
core values in every component our
mission so a huge amount of not only
continuing to develop yourself as a
leader but your organization is this
issue of reminding and hence in that
sense any list that's a write up a
organization is probably the right list
but underneath it and right if you go to
the next one please
the that what I think as I look at who
have emerged as successful leaders are
crate fulfilling environments for other
people over time they tend to have these
sort of core points of view core values
things that are in their being and that
allows them to do all those other things
without it being painful and londo
break-ins they first of all they're
committed then people know they're
committed and that can be to a
particular set of values a particular
type of environment or whatever but
there's a there's a palpable commitment
which is deeply held and not tactical
and not just situational but beyond that
setting there personally secure it is so
but you're gonna have weaknesses people
in organization are gonna have
weaknesses if you can't get to the point
where you can get up in front of a crowd
and say you know what I'm I'm Caty
that's what they call me at work I got a
lot of feedback and I
micromanaging Wyden and this next year I
get a lot of feedback and I'm showing
too much anger when someone
underperforms it's fine to give
objective feedback totally inappropriate
unfair for CEO to show anger these are
all real examples by the way Katie you
know this year well you got rid of that
anger thing that was good but in debates
you sort of have to be right you know
and you have the benefit of position
then why don't you grow up and stop
having to be right and so if you can't
get to the point and these are all
real-world examples on unfortunately the
some of which I've conquered and so much
I haven't then you're not on the path to
being a great leader now you're not
personally secure enough to face the
truth and discuss it with people and
your organization's never gonna be never
gonna be and I mean where you going to
tell them what's what's wrong with them
where they have to grow they don't
necessarily want to listen to you much
because they said well what are you
yapping at me for about micromanagement
or this behavioral deficiency because
because your faults are legendary Kent
and until we that's how we get them out
on the table just back off
so it's a very big deal this personally
secure communicates them by that it's
nothing that anything to do with the
ability to articulate your ability to
speak the communication is primarily
nonverbal when it comes to leadership
the fact you can give a good speech only
matters if everything you've done before
and everything you've done after it
supports it everything you've done
behaviorally in terms of decisions
otherwise in fact the speech is a huge
negative yeah because people look up
there and say it's a fraud or maybe
something short of that but not
reinforcing not powerful not motivating
not instructive so communicating is
about listening in particular so what's
one thing we do at divita is it's a rule
every executive at divita when every
year any place where there's more eight
teammates you have to do a town hall
that's expected now of course sometimes
it happens it just can't quite work but
there's hundreds and hundreds of town
halls I personally do lots and lots of
town halls everywhere all over divita
every year and it doesn't really matter
what gets discussed of course it matters
to some extent what really matters is
that they get to hear any question being
asked any advice being given and they
get to see how a leader an alleged
leader responds in public all the time
and we get is it people
come through some other companies and
they say we have seen the CEO or the CEO
or the see whatever more times in the
last two years than we ever saw the CEO
or whomever in the previous 15 years and
they don't bring up they don't say and
can't you made a good comment or you
said something smart they just say no
you were there you listened you answered
the questions that's that sort of works
that sort of works very powerfully
that's that's communication that's
communication and it's huge it's huge
because they're back to this thing where
leadership is a human skill and is that
old saying they don't they don't care
how much you know until they know how
much you care and if you're not willing
to get out there and listen and have a
team that goes out there and listens and
it communicates through their actions in
those kind of ways then the rest of
stuff just doesn't the leadership train
stops it just does being accountable is
a big deal when we do our annual we call
State of the village speech to all sorts
of people including shareholders the
first slide is always the areas where
the CEO and the CFO being myself in this
yellow underperformed that's that we
started off with because how are we
going to talk about all the rest of the
stuff and to tell you some of the good
stuff and other people's failures unless
we kick it off by talking about ours it
turns out accountability is just one of
the most powerful differentiators
because relatively few leaders get it
right well it's only a few leaders we'll
just calmly stand up and say you know
what this went wrong and and and I own
it I own you know what I'm not going to
blame the wind I'm not gonna blame the
budget and you know just you know
there's a whole lot of extending and
what happens is the audience will start
if you take accountability people will
start to say well you know what that
budget was kind of screwed up to start
with well you know what we never knew
the competitor was gonna do that they
will they will fill in the rest if you
start from a spot which says you know
I'm accountable for that I own this and
if you don't do that it gets very
difficult when you want to own successes
there's level when people every year you
have people come in halfway through a
year and and certain people are behind
budget and they go well if following six
unexpected uncontrollable things went
wrong that's why I'm behind budget now
no one comes halfway through the year
that's ahead of budget and says the
following unexpected uncontrollable
things happen and that's why I'm ahead
of budget so it's a fascinating world
out there
only works one way the only bad
unexpected things happen never a good
unexpected thing happens and then lastly
a the most powerful leaders serve they
serve the cause or they serve the people
they serve some combination when
people's sense that you're the boss you
get to make decisions you get paid more
you get a bigger office whatever that is
they don't they don't mind that as long
as you serve the cause that they serve
or you serve them or both that's that is
when people start to say I will follow
this person I trust this person because
they care about me and they either serve
the cause I love or they serve me or
both and again you can you can speak
into a lot of other things but if you
don't get those basics it ain't
happening it ain't happen much sooner
small seven-person investment management
firm we're really a leadership isn't
quite the same issue as it is for most
human beings out there working at
different levels I was at was at Bain I
want to be an executive I left went to a
dialysis company in 1991 it should have
been fired in the first year I was just
terrible I was intent on proving how
smart I was to a lot of people didn't
have Harvard MBAs and Stanford
undergrads if the guy who was placed I
was taking the CEO wasn't a very
generous mature man I would have been I
would have been fired wasn't so I got to
sort of learn I had training wheels and
an easier business I got very very lucky
I intended to leave that business within
a year or two because it was for me it
was not it was it was the opposite of a
sexy business dialysis it's a lot of
Medicare patients everyone dies so I
said I'm gonna prove I could be a CEO of
a public company and then I'm gonna go
on to something that that is more
befitting my race driver status in life
and and and what happened instead is I
fell um fell in love with it I fell in
love with it because it lots of
blue-collar Americans working hard doing
good stuff and to add value to their
lives found out to be this amazing
fulfilling thing not because I planned
it that way but it happened that way in
front of my eyes and so I didn't leave I
stayed until we got taken over
unfortunately by a much larger company
and and that's probably the only company
in the history of the New York Stock
Exchange that when the board voted that
they had to accept this offer from
European company the CEO cried in the
boardroom and it has stopped the meeting
while I cried because the because this
beautiful thing that we had going as my
sort of aspirations of building a
community were just starting to form
intellectually and functionally was
dashed by this this wonderful large
amount of cash but unfortunately which
terminated the dream of a different
place then I ran a different company and
it was a failure from which I learned
more about myself and people than I had
learned in all previous years and then I
was done I was gonna I was gonna resign
and take six to nine months off of my
family and go into the for-profit the
not-for-profit world so when I got head
hundred calls I said I would say nope
you know I'm taking six nine months off
with my family and then don't know what
I'm gonna do call me then because I
didn't want to preclude myself from
maybe change if I change my mind
and then I got a call from this dialysis
company is total renal care and I
literally picked up the phone and and
was going to give the same pitter patter
I'd given to other search firms and I'd
have no idea what I said because all
these the the memories of how my
experience in that setting were the most
fulfilling I had ever had professionally
came flooding back and I don't know what
I said I do remember the next part I
went home and my wife Denise was sitting
at her desk and I said Denise that
totally new account called which and she
looked over shoulder and said well we
weren't expecting that because I had
been a CEO in that industry and was
regarded as successful and there was a
turnaround that it was in the same state
of California and she said she said
we've been expecting that and she turned
back because of course I was supposed to
give the answer I'd given to everybody
else and and then she five six seconds
later since I'm still standing there and
she turned with a look of very intense
anger
and and sad Kent you didn't and I like a
little boy said didn't what the and and
she said you didn't tell them he would
interview for that job and I said I
didn't but I want to and so we had this
hellacious conversation because she said
you know you testosterone ego-driven
son of a gun so this big you know what
happened to the family time what
happened to this and I and I said well
you know there's there's a there's some
truth in what you're saying but there's
a salsa this other thing which I think I
think I can live my professional dream I
think I can add great value I I like
these people
this is this this is a pitch I want to
try to hit this is where I think I can I
can do everything I wanted to do if I
took a not-for-profit job I can I can
build a community here I know this place
I this is what I think I can do and once
we went up and down for a couple weeks
just just a very stress stressful time
for a marriage as we as we wrestled with
it and we decided ultimately as a family
that that we would do it because it was
at the time when I would've felt like a
burden at the time which is it was a
turnaround and I was gonna be very hard
in the family was an in LA and she made
very clear we weren't moving from this
area the Bay Area so I was gonna be
commuting up and down away from our two
kids so heavy heavy heavy issues but we
decided that this was an opportunity for
me to live my values in a way that I
might not ever get another chance to
just can't count on that
that second our kids I would probably
take away the right message that even
though daddy was gone more he was gone
because he was trying to do good and he
loved his job very very much and so we
we gave it a try and so that the burden
of that decision turned out to be a gift
because I've never entered a job with
such clarity about the end in mind and
since then we've done a whole lot of
things only recruiting folks using our
mission of values of parameter helping
develop people as human being
reinforcing this honoring those folks
who behave differently as human beings
more than we honor folks who are better
at business we reward them with greater
bonuses and stock option exercises but
we honor in the special nights and
special days we honor those people who
are better human beings not the ones
that are better businesspeople and and
so it's been this glorious adventure so
so my final sort of comment is that is
that once you find once you're near the
area that you think can allow you to
sort of an unfettered way but have your
passions express themselves in a
professional way it doesn't matter what
kind of business it is doesn't have to
be not-for-profit just jump into it with
all all your heart and soul because you
can't go very far wrong you can't go
very far wrong and too many there's an
old Indian saying it that most people go
to their graves with their music still
inside and so just be sure that as you
climb up the whatever ladder that you're
focused on that all GSB students get to
climb that you figure out where your
music is because it's terrible we have
so many 51 year old friends who are not
fulfilled they're financially very
secure and they're not fulfilled there's
in fact no correlation with our HBS
class with net worth and fulfilment and
so those are my closing thoughts thank
you very much
you